bonjour à tous on conçoit ans à l'époque
ont regardé cette vidéo c'est cyrus et
ça fait plaisir d'être sur ce plateau
qui n'en est pas un du tout ce qu'on
fait a ouvert voilà regarder et en plus
ces personnes devant moi non plus voilà
on n'ose pas eu ton plateau ça par
contre ça c'est un plateau
voilà on s'en tape les nannerl a fait
une rétrospective de ce qui s'était
passé l'année dernière donc l'aide avant
du coup 2016 bravo on y suggère que
personne dont je parle dans le vide un
essai dans ce vide et cette fois ci je
vais plutôt vous exposer ce qui va
arriver cette année et qui va vous
concerner directement à travers les lois
qui vont entrer en application
j'ai menti et à la personne yatom non
[Musique]
limitation de vitesse à 80 km heure à
partir de juillet 2018 la vitesse max
des voitures passe de 90 km heure à 80
km heure sur les routes secondaires à
double sortie
alors pourquoi il y en a qui disent que
c'est pour remplir les caisses de l'état
peut-être peut-être pas un perso si vous
voulez remplir les caisses il le ferait
avec des trucs plus simples comme des
courses par exemple on va faire les
courses les questions en plus super vite
ou même des gens sur les passagers
petite impro gratos les amendes
concernant la circulation en rapporter à
l'état 1 2 8 milliards d'euros en 2016
ton 920 millions d'euros pour les radars
donc c'est peut-être pour des questions
tu mets peut-être pas la vitesse
excessive reste la cause de mortalité
numéro un sur les routes devant l'alcool
et la fatigue et c'est à la hausse
depuis 2013 avec 3477 mort en 2016 et
s'y met ça en place seulement sur les
routes secondaires à double sens c'est
parce qu'elle représente 40% du réseau
mais c'est là qu'il y à 55 % des décès
ceux qui sont contre cette loi disent
que le remplacement des panneaux coûte
cher alors c'est vrai c'est chiffré à
1,6 million d'euros
mais les accidents corporels en 2016 a
coûté 38,3 milliards donc un vote soit
12.2 mesure les vaccins obligatoires
hors sujet polémique ça va jaser déjà
petite piqûre de rappel n'engage à rien
a rappelé et c'était juste pour la mad à
partir du 1er janvier 2018
il a été décidé par le gouvernement de
rendre obligatoire pense vaccins pour
les jeunes enfants contre trois
actuellement et pas que 50 ans
coqueluche rougeole oreillons rubéole
hépatite b lac terry est mauvais et ma
fille et mon fils usa il ya plein
d'autres vaccins et je pense
personnellement que c'est une bonne
chose
voilà je le dis c'est
une bonne chose pour tous les anti pacs
qui me regarde je vous respecte au fort
et même je vous aime mais j'aimerais
vous demander de regarder les vidéos
qu'on fait mes compères bourse
julien ménielle et thomas durand
montmélian déception je ne peux
m'empêcher d'espérer que ça vous fera
changer d'avis et d'ailleurs en parlant
de changer d'avis voici changer d'avis
d'imposition suppression de la taxe
d'habitation
vous savez cette transition ou pas à bas
le soutenons le souci c'est que c'est
pas très logique avec le plan parce que
j'aurais bien aimé traité de la
fiscalité dans un seul bloc et j'ai pas
fini sur d'autres trucs donc à temps on
va remettre le hausse d'octobre truc
alors concernant les os traditionnel du
début d'année il ya le diesel l'essence
le gaz en janvier le tabac en mars et
encore une gestion bout de l'année à
l'autre
le timbre le temps voilà 2 5% environ au
niveau amendes de stationnement ça
augmente et sa baisse en même temps
globalement ça augmente mais en fait ça
dépend des villes en gros jusqu'à
maintenant on oublié de payer à
l'horodateur payer 17 euros où qu'on
soit en france et maintenant il n'y a
plus d'armes classiques
c'est un forfait poste stationnement la
thune revient en collectivité et c'est
aussi elle qui fixe le montant par
exemple c'est 60 euros à lyon et 10
euros à castin c'est la suppression de
la taxe d'habitation
voilà donc on peut revenir à ce que je
le vous dire avant la grosse promesse d'
emmanuel macron 80% des ménages devrait
donc payer 30% de moins sur leur taxe
d'habitation en 2018
65 % de moins en 2019 et plus rien en
2020 c'est aussi pour ça que les
collectivités doit trouver de nouvelles
sources de financement suppression de l'
isf
alors il ya d'autres impôts qui sont
supprimées et pas forcément ce que vous
payez ou alors je m'en vais peut-être de
checker mappage tipi les formats vidéo
évidemment je veux parler de la
suppression de l' isf impôt sur la
fortune
il va être remplacé par lee et fit un
pas sur la fortune immobilière en gros
avant les plus fortunés et déclarer
l'intégralité de leur patrimoine
alice yachts voitures de luxe maisons
maisons vacances iphone 10 etc
au delà d'un des 2 3 millions d'euros il
devait payer l'isf aujourd'hui le
patrimoine immobilier sera taxée
seulement lui pas le reste le ciel reste
le même donc forcément il y aura moins
de gens qu'ils vont payer environ 150000
personnes de moins et ça devrait coûter
à l'état 3 2 milliards d'euros par le
gouvernement explique l'objectif c'est
de maintenir les plus riches en france
et encourager leurs investissements des
entreprises et d'ailleurs la mise du
travail mary pénicaud bas du cou
économiser
deux mille euros d isf elle s'est
engagée à les investir si muriel la flat
tax pour vous expliquer la flat tax jeu
de vous expliquer les revenus du capital
évidemment je ne parle pas de l'émission
de tv qui était présenté par un mec qui
a un très gros sourcils en gros les
revenus du capital c'est le revenu lié
aux intérêts au d'évidentes par exemple
avant s'est imposé avec un barème
progressif avec un maximum de 68 5%
maintenant c'est prélèvement forfaitaire
unique imposée à 30% pour tout le monde
apprécie le mode progressif était plus
intéressant pour vous vous pouvez
choisir de rester sur ce mode là c'est
la même logique qu'il ya derrière la
suppression de l'isf moins taxer le
capital pour booster les investissements
après pour pouvoir financer cette perte
les gouvernements se reposent sur
diverses réformes mais j'espère qu'il va
pas se reposer très longtemps parce que
quand même du taf voilà les deux
réformes dont je vous parlais elle
favorise les plus riches ou moins court
terme mais le gouvernement fait le pari
qu'à long terme ça profitera à tous
on vient hausse de la contribution
sociale généralisée
la contribution sociale généralisée
c'est en gros des charges sociales ça va
augmenter de 1 17%
ça devrait rapporter 22,5 milliards
d'euros par an au gouvernement
donc c'est quand même pas mal ça
s'applique à toutes les catégories de
revenus salaires revenus du capital et
retraite alors après c'est compensé par
d'autres suppressions de cotisations
sociales mais le problème c'est que 60 %
des retraités ne bénéficieront pas de la
suppression de ces cotisations là après
le gouvernement répond que la taxe
d'habitation diminue donc ça qu'on pense
quand même bon là on compense par ci ou
compense par là moi tant qu'on pense à
temps comment ça me va on va vous
mettrez des biens d'exception s'ils
voulaient creuser aulas des liens aussi
soulage t d les pelles et où j'arrête
j'arrête baisse des apl on en avait
parlé en octobre dernier tout le monde
dès vénère ils maintiennent la loi et
pour l'immobilier privé
enfin la matinée aussi pour les
logements sociaux mais en fait ça
devrait pas se voir parce que le loyer
va passer du même montant en même temps
et ça à faire gagner à l'état 800
millions d'euros en 2018 hausse des
indemnités de stage alors calme toi
jeune stagiaire calme-toi tombale pas
parce que je te jure que c'est pas où
est
mais en gros la vérité de ce stage
minimum augmente de 20 euros
ça fait quand même quatre paniers
mélenchon hockey enfin trois vu qu'on
enlève les 5 euros d'apl c'est déjà cool
non
on fait avec ce qu'on a ok suppression
des microbilles un peu d'environnement
ça ne fait pas de mal
1 tous blancs parce qu'en fait sans
environnement il peut pas y avoir
d'existence dans un monde sensoriel et
concret donc forcément oui un peu
d'environnement ça fait pas de mal donc
ça n'a aucun sens de dire ça je voulais
dire un peu d'écologie désole un peu
d'écologie les microbilles sont
interdits depuis janvier dans les
produits cosmétiques
c'est des trucs qu'on trouvait dans le
gommage pour visage savons shampooings
dentifrices et surtout pas les
lubrifiants ou alors c'est chelou
selon une étude publiée par la revue
time en 2015 ces 8000 milliards de micro
billes de plastique qui vont dans la mer
et qui perturbe les écosystèmes aux
antilles donc c'est cool qu'on est suivi
certains états du canada et des états
unis
là dessus un peu quoi le lobby des
microbilles doit être vraiment naze
voilà j'espère que cette vidéo vous a
plu c'est pas le cas vous invite à vous
rendre compte de ce que vous regardez en
cours de route et partir avant si vous
avez l'impression qu'on a raté certains
points c'est tout à fait normal
il a fallu faire une sélection et
certains sujets sont encore débattues et
pour l'aller au travail je ferai
peut-être une vidéo consacrée support le
temps que j'ai il ya plein de liens en
description aussi vous renseigner
davantage sur ce dont on a parlé vous
invite à aller faire un tour sur mon
tipi pour me soutenir et à partager la
vidéo c'est les deux trucs les plus
importantes puisse y perd en dehors de
tabasser le bouton like et de lâcher un
commentaire love peace now